world championship tournament with an
odd was it easier harder roughly as
expected how would you and you won quite
decisively six and a half to three and a
half is the best out of 12 12.
well first of all I I had a long time to
prepare uh I prepared a lot
but I think I probably
um it probably scared me a little a
little bit to to go through all of
anan's gains from the past because I
realized
how extremely strong how diverse his
strengths are uh
and that made me a little bit
a little bit scared
um
and when I got to the first game I was a
little bit
nervous
I played a little bit of an offbeat line
but which I thought could still give me
a slight Advantage then I made a mistake
which it turned out
um it was a normal theoretical move
which turned out to be a mistake and he
replied quite quickly
and I had to basically beg for a draw
with why it's pretty early on which was
not a a great result at all and that
made me even more nervous and scared
because I thought if he uh
if he's that well prepared even in some
offbeat sideline then
what the hell am I supposed to to do
um
then in the second game I I made a
fairly easy draw uh in the third game
with white I I messed up pretty badly
after the opening and I got a difficult
position
and at some point he really needed to
play sharply
um
in order to gain an advantage and to
play for a win he didn't do that he
simplified towards a draw instead and I
think that was
a huge mistake
um
he I think in such much uh you need to
take every little chance uh that is
presented to you because once you're
ahead it starts to
yeah because I don't think you you can
have he really wanted complete comfort
in the way that he wanted to wait for an
even better chance that that was the
problem he wasn't getting a better
chance the whole match uh and then I
realized that he was not he was not in
the mindset the pounds yet and at that
point I felt pretty confident
that I would eventually grind him down
game four was was I think a wonderful
game uh I was black I gained the
advantage
he defended very resourcefully
um I made some inaccuracies but overall
I thought it was a very good game it was
a draw but uh but nevertheless it left
me with a great feeling and I carried
that over to the fifth and sixth games
and from then on it was just a dream I
won the fifth game I won the sixth game
and I was really of course a dream
scenario from then on I I was not
nervous before any of the games I was
just feeling
like my preparation is working well with
black uh he can't beat me
basically so
then I just had Supreme confidence in
that I was going to have a successful
results are there players that you found
you've played over time been tougher
than an odd or are there certain types
of players that you find
it's usually hard well when I started
out
um playing the top level tournaments
Anand was really the only player who
consistently beat me up he had a winning
record against you before the world
championship match yeah he won he won
like five games in in a couple of years
uh with a few draws which is which is
quite a lot and he also at that time
dominated me in
in Rapid blindfold and avoids chess but
eventually as as I got better I started
winning a couple of games against him
and with my three wins in the
in World Championship I finally
equalized my life lifetime score with
him congratulations well we should um
[Applause]
thank you